[Music]  on your knees with your hands behind  your head  that's far enough i tried to help him i  swear  on me  we are at war and the war is secret this  unit is the last line of defense against  a truly terrifying force  condition to kill but also to deceive  we shall continue the operation but do  not engage  they took me when i was four years old  they kept me prisoner they  did things to me i can protect you  no you want me to trust you enhanced  i've been turning up dead all across the  country  one of your own taking you down from the  inside  there's no safety and no control we will  all die  nothing will save me  his body is human and it still bleeds  but he regenerates instantly  david can't open the doorway until he's  harvested every single subject  will come for you and i had nothing to  do with that know it  none of them did they're not people  they're weapons  he's coming for them and anyone's  standing in his way  [Music]  [Music]  you